quite a set we call ourselves cyber cat
exotics we have 30 cats we started out
as a cat rescue about 25 years ago
lately they've been supporting
themselves because it's really hard to
support you know there's many cats the
cats actually have an agent just like a
movie star would have an agent and I'm
the cat star mom they just know how to
communicate with me in every single way
and most of the time I don't have to
give them any treats or rewards I just
ask them to do stuff the cats love doing
this kind of work
hi Gary I love that outfit is that
United bamboo six has been on a lot of
shows she's very very famous kitty they
export her by name and the reason her
name is six is because she has six toes
on each hand she's done inside Amy
Schumer six here also did 30 rock she's
got a little relationship going on with
James Franco she did a little short film
with James Franco it's called the cat
father/daughter and six played Francis
you went high with the Godfather right
and she loves James Franco so we made a
little deal that they have to date now
because he said he loves her
she was kissing him tell him you could
tell him it's this right we have
different cats that have different
portfolios people can call me the crazy
cat lady I don't care plus these guys
give me the most unconditional love in
the world then give me kisses